going to begin again in california where
record-setting wildfires are spreading
up and down the west coast this morning
and hot dry and very windy weather
dramatic video shared on twitter shows a
fiery explosion as the flames destroyed
homes
in a city called talent in southwestern
oregon that's near medford
traffic was backed up on roads after
widespread evacuations were ordered in
that area
washington's governor reported more fire
damage in one day
than they see in an average year the
fire threat continues
in much of california three firefighters
were hurt
one critically when flames overran their
position
the national guard was out in force
pulling campers to safety
carter evans reports from just outside
los angeles where entire communities
have been told to prepare to evacuate
powerful gusts of hot dry wind are
fueling the california wildfires
the bobcat fire about 30 miles east of
los angeles
has residents preparing for the worst
the santa ana winds worry me a lot
when they kick up i don't think the
firefighters have a chance
after doubling in size the dolan fire
burning in rugged terrain along the
central coast
forced 14 firefighters to deploy their
emergency shelters tuesday
when you deploy a fire shelter that's
kind of a last
chance for survival so you take the fire
shelter out of your pack and you crawl
into it
in oregon the governor declared a
wildfire emergency tuesday
four large fires continue to devastate
clackamas county south of portland
thousands of people have been told to
leave their homes
further south this video shows sheriff's
deputies driving through what's left of
mill city
hot dry conditions the red flag warnings
and certainly 30 mile an hour winds have
really impacted our communities
back in california at the creek fire
near fresno the national guard
used military helicopters for the second
time
to rescue more than a hundred campers in
the sierra national forest
it was just this huge billowing cloud it
was like a nuclear bomb exploded it was
crazy
each flight was capped off with a
heartwarming reunion on the ground
that's a hell of a way to get a ride on
the helicopter boys
mary breckinridge was overjoyed to have
her son
back in her arms i'm happy that she's
happy
it was pretty nasty it was smoky up
there
we didn't know what was going to happen
california has already set a record with
more than 2
million acres burned this year and the
season is only just beginning
leaving many communities on edge if we
do get a spark that wind could just
potentially take it
and it can go really quick
this is one of the communities
firefighters are concerned about now
right now the winds are pretty calm so
things are in good shape but
if you could see over my shoulder there
right on the top of the ridge
the fire is just starting to creep over
and that's the big concern
because these winds could pick up today
and blow those flames
right down into this neighborhood so far
this fire is ten thousand acres
and it's zero percent contained a little
close for comfort there carter carter
evans for us carter thank you very much